تاي
وو
إنه يوم جديد ، مرات عديدة ، أشياء أمام منزل ماناكا
تم القبض عليه بواسطة JB و Dow Damon و 4 Li Damo
هكذا أوم شارتر سون كيف كامب
كلمة هي بيان كوريا للوئام بريسون
قانون غربال المروحة
مرحبا في المنزل ، مرحبا دائما
شدها أكثر إذا رأيت ذلك
أوه كيف تأتي الرائحة وتذهب
معدن A Court Centara Rain و Amu
من المحتمل أن تكون البرشاء بها الكثير من الرياضات
أنا أكره أنه لم يفعل ذلك ، فهو لا يزال والد إن ها
2 جيجابايت واحد
أوه
في البداية
كنت في الأصل سأقوم بتحميله ، ولكن بعد ذلك
لأنني أصبحت مساعدًا
لقد جئت إلى هنا مرة أخرى بفرصة جيدة
إنه نوع من الوقت المناسب لي حقًا
نفس الشيء ومرة ​​أخرى
بقدر ما أتيت ، فإن الوقت الذي أملكه مع المعجبين
يجب أن أصنع الكثير من الذكريات الجيدة.
أعددت بجد ، أعدت بجد ، آه
خمسة
ألن تكون مرحلة رائعة جدًا؟
فعل
في منتصف اللون الأسود ، آه ، لمست إطار الباب
قليلا من سماعات باريس الخريف
1 1 2 2 أخرى
في خضم البحث والعمل معًا
علي أن أعمل
ما مدى صعوبة الأمر وليس مجرد تجربة
أعطني بعض الخبرة
كلاسيكي جديد لذا فهو أكثر متعة وقليلًا
إنه صعب ، لكني أعيش الوظيفة
إنه صعب جسديًا وعقليًا
يجب أن تكون هناك أجزاء ، لكن المشكلة مثيرة للاهتمام
أعتقد أنه تحد
الذي - التي
[موسيقى]
والأدوية لا تستطيع صنع أي شيء على الإطلاق
كما أن لوز Tenny غير الناضج مرؤوسون مختلفون
أنا لا أمسك بـ 5 أشياء ، إذا كان هناك عودة
اليماني شائع عند النظر إلى الجانب الآخر من هامان
Orochi 4 4 2 طريقة تانابي مرة أخرى
شريط الاستثمار ريشة سوداء في اليوم تمتص الكثير
لم أجب ، أشعر بأوميا مالحة
لم يكن كذلك
أوه
بادئ ذي بدء ، فيلم أو شيء من هذا القبيل
النظر إلى كتاب أو طبل
الآن الفكرة هي فكرة
ابدأ العمل واحصل على الإلهام هناك
أميل إلى الحصول على الكثير وبعد ذلك
لأنني أميل إلى تخيل الكثير
قليلا من هناك ، لذلك فهي تؤثر
أعتقد أنه سيكون غير مريح للغاية و
بمجرد أن تبدأ العمل
شيئا ما
فكر في الأمر كألبوم ،
اعتقدت أنني يجب أن أقوم بعمل أغانٍ مناسبة
وفكرت في الصورة الكبيرة
أنا لا أعمل وأنا
أكثر
في هذه الأيام ، المنتج المسمى Sunrise هو أكثر قليلاً
إنها حقًا ، وليست شركة.
يا إلهي
السبب هو
لا أعلم ، فقط بهذه الحالة المزاجية هذه الأيام
يجب أن ترى تشغيل هيونغ
هذا أيضا
[موسيقى]
بارد
حقبة
سرطان الرئة
يذكرني بالغزل المتعلق بـ Dawn Train Guy
كتب
مرة واحدة فرعية الرئيسية تعاني من كل شيء
الجنس الخامس
والد ياري ، فذهبت ورأيت سيارة
أوه
ربما مختلفة الآن
الأغنية التي أغنيها للناس
التفكير والكتابة كثيرا
أعتقد أن هذا صحيح ، أنا أحب ألوانهم
لأنك تعتقد أنك يجب أن تعطي
لذا أنا
القليل من الخيال
يبدو أنني أكتب الأغاني أثناء القيام بالكثير.
كأفضل مطر الآن
عندما تكتب أغنية
في ذلك الوقت ، أنا
ماذا اريد ان اعبر
ما نوع القصة التي تريد أن تحكيها أولاً؟
بعد التفكير كثيرا ، إذن
انا اعمل وهذه النقاط قليلا
يبدو مختلفًا
نسيت ارتداء Stark Tiamat's North What
هل تعلم أن لدي قبضة ماء ، لكن انسخ
سنهوا د أن يكون الأسلوب
يا له من نائب أكسا روب 1 صريم
فعلت سيجما لكنها كانت نوتة موسيقية
أوه
بالنسبة لي ، عودة GOT7 هي الأكثر
أعتقد أنه شيء جيد و
أوه ، كان هذا هو الأكثر فخرًا ، إذن
إذا فعلت ذلك ، فعندما تكتب عودة GOT7
لأولئك منكم الذين انتظروا قليلا
أعتقد أنني عملت بجد
فعلت وندمت
لا أعتقد ذلك ، مثل مثالي
لا ندم ، فقط 4 5
اعتقدت أنني كنت أتعلم
أه لا يوجد أنت مرة أخرى اختر طريقتك الخاصة ، نعم مرة أخرى
لأنني أعتقد أنه مفترق طرق
آه
[موسيقى]
لي
آه
eww
دي جي مع الكثير من سطح السفينة راديو فون الإنجليزية
هل كوم 2 ر a ديسيبل
مارشال يو وآن سيلفر آرثر في الخارج
لقد كتبتها ، لكنني سأستخدمها كأم ، لذا سأضعها معًا أولاً
سي-يا ، هذا سيء للغاية ، ماء.
تعويذة مائية 3 Lori Her Summon Link
1 غيغابايت Irunmak برعاية Long Red Deer
سوكار ليس طعامًا ، كان تيلر موك.
أه ، أعتقد أنها موسيقى
أوه
بادئ ذي بدء ، لأنني قدمت الكثير من الموسيقى
أمي ضعيفة بعض الشيء هذه الأيام
هل لديك أي أفكار حول التمثيل؟
لكن يبدو أنها موسيقى وهذا
لون المظهر قليلا بشكل عام
إذا عبرت عن
طائر أزرق
هل أنت
عند استخدام نفس الاسم مثل jb
أعتقد أن اللون الأزرق يناسبك جيدًا.
البارحة ، لون هذا الشخص الحقيقي
إنه ليس أزرق
بالنسبة للمقال ، إنه سرير أزرق
نعم نعم نعم نعم اه
بعض الشيء
5 افعل شيئًا حيويًا
أرني الكثير من القوات الممتعة
أريد أن أريكم هكذا أفعل
شيء من هذا القبيل
الطول الكامل أداء مكثف ومثير
لا أستطيع حتى أن أقول إنه رائع وجيد ، لكن هذا
إنه أكثر قليلاً من ذلك ، لكنه مرح
بعض المزيد من المشاكل الممتعة
الرياء يناسبني بشكل أفضل
أعتقد أنه يشبه اللون الأزرق قليلاً
أدخل
[موسيقى]
نحن
نحن نحن
[موسيقى]
آه ، لقد تمطر الآن لمدة 9 دقائق
لا تخبرني أن أصعد إلى مبنى كريم باجا القديم
عندما تم بيع الدخل من قبل ، غالبًا 3
أعني ، عليك أن تعرف أول أفضل لقطة
العيش لمدة شهر والعيش في الشهر الماضي
مرحبًا ، إليك كيف يتدفق الساشيمي
من الذي يجب أن يكون حريصًا بشأن من وماذا
يجب أن تكون جيدًا في شيء ما
هذا صحيح إذا كنت تتعلم الأشياء فقط
هل تعتقد أنه لا يوجد
ماذا او ما
نعم نعم هذا مضحك بعض الشيء
ألن تكون تجربة
وي
آه آه
حسنًا ، أتناول الكثير من الطعام المحلي
أريد أن أحصل عليه وأذهب إلى هناك
نفس
نعم ، لم أمتلك تجربة جيدة جدًا حتى الآن.
5 بيرل لم تمرض ، ولكن
مثل هذا الطعام
أوه ، هذا الأخ لديه منشأة جيدة ، أليس كذلك؟
لقد رأيت
ذهبت أيضًا ونظرت إلى الزهور البيضاء المحلية أكثر من ذلك بقليل.
إذا لم تفعل هذا بعد النظر إلى الديدان الخيطية
أعتقد أنه سيكون جيدًا
eww
[موسيقى]
الإصدار
هز براعم لا تفكك ولكن
غرفة هاري المطيرة 1p إيفرتون أنارا
الرضا الذي يجب إفراغه هو 0 أ ، مثل الهتاف للإلهة
مثل هذه العربة الجوالة
سرير توقفت به من أجل نان هاسي
لا يمكنني لفها بشكل جيد ومنظم سلم 1
سوف يتغير آه
آه
أوه
آه نحن آه
لا ، من الناحية الواقعية سوف يستغرق بعض الوقت.
أتساءل عما إذا كان
أنا أيضا شيء
7 أشخاص من الجولة إلى الجولة الحجرية
يتجول لأشهر
أوه
مرحبًا ، إنها مثل مدرسة ثانوية للطاقة ، مثل هذا
بشكل كاف
أتمنى ألا أضطر إلى الأداء.
أوه
اكتبها كلها 2 3 4 نعم ذلك
كم سنة سيستغرق الأمر
أظن
إنه صغير ، لكني أحاول وأحاول
هناك
آه 5 مثلك تعرف فاتورة سعيدة
بخلاف ذلك ، فهو باب يمكن استخدامه حتى في حالة استخدامه
إذا كان من الشائع من 5 ، اللثة الأشياء
دعونا نأكل نقطة وصول ساكي على أكمل وجه
ستعرف أنك ستحب مثل هذه الشخصية
تعال مرة أخرى ، واتبع خطة Rigon Moju
هذه المرة يجب أن أتحلى بالصبر لشربه
هم الناس
أوه
أنا على اتصال بك في كثير من الأحيان أتواصل معك كثيرًا
الرجاء التواصل
بيع مل 4
أوه ، هذا لا يبدو كثيرًا
أه كم مرة في الأسبوع نعم تواصلوا معي كثيرًا
أنا أميل إلى
وأنشطة بعضنا البعض بشكل جيد
مثله
ألقي نظرة عليها وعندما يكون لدي الوقت مرة أخرى
فضة
يجتمع ويتحدث عن المشاكل
إنها طريقة جيدة لقضاء الوقت معًا
أعتقد أن هذا هو سبب بقائها على هذا النحو
أعتقد أنه قد يكون كذلك ، هم Hyejin
ما هي الملصقات التي تجلس عليها عندما تحاول؟
آه
حديثاً
لقد تحدثت إلى جين هيونغ على الهاتف ، نعم جين يونغ
بالاتصال
ما هو jinyoung
رأيت الصورة تلتقط جيدًا
شكرا لك على الحديث
أنت مشغول جدًا هذه الأيام ، ما الذي تتحدث عنه؟
ل
لم يكن السبب
eww
هذا صحيح ، لذلك حتى لو ركبت مع مقارنة صغيرة فقط
مثل هذا ، m1 هو الكثير من الاستثمار في المشاريع الكورية
لدرجة أن جهاز التوجيه الأول غير قابل للاستخدام
يا ما في القاع
4 من أين أنت قادم ، إيه جي الحافلة
كلمة تسمى
ألبومي الثاني خارج
استعدت بجد وبسرعة في فترة قصيرة من الزمن
قلت لنعد البوم
حسنًا ، أردت ذلك أيضًا
مع
أعددت قليلا على عجل
الجودة جيدة جدا
لذلك عندما سمع المشجعون
نحن سوف
سأصبح أم مرحة وشفاء مثل هذا
اعتقد لذلك استمتع بوقتك
أعتقد أنه يمكنني إرسالها
ماذا علي أن آخذ؟ يعجبني. ابحث قبل 2
2 آه آه قليلا
هذه المرة ، جذع آسيا الصغرى ، وهو رخيص الثمن من الخلف ، هو y
انظر إلى كل عصير الأيونات في وعاء كبير
نعم أوه آه
ليس الأمر ليس كذلك
أوه إنه لاحقًا
أنا لا أعتقد ذلك
الآن هو
قليلا من نوع الأعمال الحضرية
القليل
إمالة اللبن الرائب الكلاب ستارك ماري
أكثر أوه نعم ، nc في الطرف الغربي
إذا لم تكن جيدًا في Kepa ، إذا كنت تريد شراء 7 و 9 من نفس الشيء
أكل كما تفعل حقنة 8 لتر
اه اه اه
عندما تفكر قليلا
أوه
تحاول جاهدة حماية GOT7
يبدو أن دور الكيان و
اعتقد و
بالنسبة لي
أنا أستعد بجد لألبوماتي الشخصية أيضًا.
نشاط صعب للغاية
ولكن ماذا
استرخ قليلاً وكن مرتاحًا الآن
اعتقدت أنه يجب علي الترويج لألبوم
آه
التي
أه أحدث ألبوم يصدر أولاً
آمل أن تكون قد خرجت بشكل جيد ، لقد فعلت ذلك بعد ذلك
جهز جسمك على الفور وفي المرة القادمة
أنا أفكر ، لذلك ستذهب الشمس
ما holic بواسطة 4
الصعب
4 في الوقت الحاضر
فكر في العمل الجاد
لا ، لقد كتبت 8
أوه
بشريا
فقط كن هادئا
العمل الجاد
في بعض الأحيان مع شيء هادئ
ويجب
ثم عد مرة أخرى مثل هذا
سيكون مفيدا
حزمة فروة الرأس القاتمة الصيفية مرتدية Pippi
إنها جائزة. ألق نظرة عليها.
أوه تعال مثل هذا
[صفق]
[موسيقى]
آه
آه شكرا آه آه آه آه
نعم انا 4
ل
بجد بجد
سأكون نشيطا
لقد استمعت جيدًا إلى كلمات الدعم.
لقد تأثرت. سيكون لطيفا ، لكن هذا الفيديو
من هذا القبيل وتلك الرسالة وهذا النوع من الأشياء متماثلان بعض الشيء
تغرب الشمس
حسنًا ، المزيد من الناس في المستقبل
هناك العديد من الفرص التي يمكن رؤيتها في كثير من الأحيان
أتمنا لو كان هنالك
eww
انتهيت مع enq
[موسيقى]
اشعر بها
امتلك دعنا نكبر
سقسقة
[موسيقى]